walk him to this video against porn do
Xuan yeah this guy has profited a lot
from my recent ratings slump lost two
games against him that is set a 6-1
score now it is 63 mm-hmm again idea
three is a very I'm sorry about that is
a very modest way to to play that mmm he
plays in gambit star against this I
don't know that can I take this may be
the capture and queen d 5 on f7 I mean
and I not sure how good this is then
seemed okay here I thought I can maybe
take and play Bishop e7 just just keep
it simple
now I have no experience with Knight f3
knight b3 sometimes gets played against
me and after that you can can really
grab grab the material here the night is
on f3 not good it ok I should should
keep this yes this is possible f7 hang
so I need to take him tarra white as a
white as an active position here for
sure ok i get d 5 and now that's that's
good news
yeah I should be okay it's equal
material I have something to take on c3
yeah this should be okay I don't really
see a big attacking idea fy5 is not
doing much and just with pieces I don't
know
no take twice I'm going to get Bishop
age 70 not not good
Quincy seven I could play maybe then
take
I can take down at the end this f 5m no
it's not not so good
I were to do how to play him
it should be on d3 is also slight
problem maybe I can maybe I can exchange
something here takes Bishop c4 or Bishop
a two and then Bishop c4 it could be
could be a good way to exchange some
pieces
the next Bishop see form to get this
written to get this attacking bishop off
Green age three I could be a more h6
Bishop f5 ok I'm going to play this year
anyway
I don't think that this was a very lucky
choice unless I'm overlooking something
here which is possible very much
possible Bishop h7s I think not possible
King takes Queen 83 check king gee ed
Brooke h5 g6 and I'm covering a jade
that would be weird of it worked and on
rook age 5 or something are take t3 and
then see to
no problem is he cannot take C for Queen
takes is attacking both ropes and Queen
d3s yeah as good as resigning basically
hmm he needs to do something drastic now
white resign yeah he didn't see anything
drastic interesting computer still is
pretty I mean he said computer gives
stockfish gives this that's just a pawn
for black now why can't continue here of
course yeah but it's basically in
exchange here here between 83 was
interesting again this was much better
the problem is I'm threatening it's the
main threat and h6 Queen f5 is is very
bad for black losing I must play this
and this is a far better version of of
the position like this maybe this is
playable what whitey is perfectly okay
he has f5 it's um yeah compass on 0.3 so
very slight edge for why'd you know in a
blitz game anything anything can happen
I wasn't sure how to play him yeah rook
e8 as the stock for smooth just putting
it on the half-open phone yeah I wanted
to get get some stuff exchanged computer
prefers this am okay nerves of steel or
loss of is it silicon okay it gives
black a pawn advantage okay i have the
better structure and everything but it's
so feels like white has some attack
going don't don't know
and at least this was okay here and who
would resign this a bit early but he
also was a minute down on the clock okay
thanks for watching